. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY RECALL TO HEARING THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WILL. WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM RIGHT NOW SO WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO IS MOVE FORCES
LITTLE BIT HOUSEKEEPING. SOME
INVESTORS A SKEWS ME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING IS WITHDRAWN AB
FORTY FROM CONSIDERATION FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. MISTER SPEAKER
HAS APPOINTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KILEY TO REPLACE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WELCOME. AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO WELCOME TWO NEW CONSULTANTS
TO THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE CHRISTINE CASEY AND
CHANEL MANY. SO WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE MEASURES ON CONSENT
TODAY MEASURE ITEM TO AB. ONE
FORTY FIVE FRAZIER. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWO TWO SIX
MATHIS. HELLO WE WILL BE MAKING
A MOTION ON THE CONSENT UNTIL
WE HAVE THE QUORUM SO WHAT
WE'LL DO IS WE'LL START THIS.
OFFICE A SUBCOMMITTEE. OF
MOVING FORWARD AND WE DO HAVE
OUR AUTHOR. AT THE PODIUM SO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY NINETY
FOUR. SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR
HERE'S ME FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR.
WE JUST WERE SEEN IF YOU'RE
CHECKING. AND PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. AFTER MY TWO
MEN MAKE ON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I WHAT I
THINK THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY. AB
FIFTY NINETY FOUR WILL ENSURE
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN
PLACE FOR EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
AROUND THE ELECTRIFICATION OF
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
INTEREST RATES THREE LARGEST
PORTS. CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD ADVANCE
CLEAN TRUCK PROGRAM LOOK CELERY
THE ADOPTION OF ELECTRIC IN
MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS. AB
FIFTY NINETY FOUR WILL
COMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM AND
WORK TO ACHIEVE OUR LEGISLATIVE
GOALS IN THE REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE GASES. I WILL KEEP
WORKING TO FOCUS AND FINE TUNE
THE BILL WITH THE HELP OF OUR
INDUSTRY LEADERS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL SPECIALISTS AND-
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS. AND THE
TECHNOLOGY TO LOWER OR-
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT IS
AVAILABLE TODAY. AB FIFTY
NINETY FOUR WILL MAKE SURE WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SUPPORT AND
INTEGRATE. NEXT GENERATION OF
MOBILITY AND GET HER GREENHOUSE
GET SCHOOLS FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON EIGHTY FIFTEEN NINETY
FOUR. OKAY A MINUTE SIX THEY
WERE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE
AND SELLS FOR MA'AM SECTOR.
FRAZIER HERE. FONG HERE
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN TO
CUNNINGHAM DALY. DEEP FRIEDMAN
GRAYSON KILEY MEDINA IS THERE
ANY O'DONNELL YOUR. GIPSON HERE.
THE GOOD. WE HAVE A QUORUM ON
THE MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. THE FIRST IN A SECOND
MISTER GIBSON AND THIS ROAD
DON'T. CONSIDER THAT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FRAZIER
RIGHT FONG HI. BERMAN HI. CHIU
CUNNINGHAM. DALY DEEP. FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HI GRAYSON. KILEY.
MEDINA NAZARIAN O'DONNELL. OKAY
MOVE ON TO- SOME REMEMBER YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF YOUR BILL I DO NOT YOU'VE
HEARD. OKAY. THIS WE HAVE SAYS
OF THIS MOTION FIRST. ANYWAY SO.
YOU ARE. HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY.
MAYBE ASSEMBLY MORE MEMBER
LENDERS WANT TO SUPPORT MY BELT.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO SPEAK TO SUPPORT THE
OTHERS BILL. MISTER MEMBER
INSHALLAH TESLIN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS HAPPY NEW
YEAR AND YOUR AUNT WE ON BEHALF
OF THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES WE
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION
ON THE BILL BUT WE APPRECIATE
AUTHORS LEADERSHIP ON IT WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY HER IDENTIFYING
THIS ISSUE WE HAVE A BROADER
GOALS FOR ELECTRIFICATION OF
OUR OPERATIONS AT THE PORT AND
OFTEN TIMES THE CHARGING
QUICKLY CAN BE AS EXPENSIVE OR
MORE THAN ACTUAL VEHICLES- WE
DO- IN GOING FORWARD WITH THIS
BILL WHICH FOR A BROADER MORE
COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATION OF
AGENCIES. THESE ISSUES TOUCH ON
PUBLIC CATION INFRASTRUCTURE AS
WELL AS OTHER CATEGORIES SO
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR HAS THE BILL
CONTINUES. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST BROWN
WHITE ON BEHALF THE PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIP ASSOCIATION WE
ALSO DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILL WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR- AND OUR
STAFF- TALKED HER STAFF ON
FRIDAY AND WE WANT TO WORK AT
THE ALSO WE APPRECIATE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. AGENDA
SUPPORT OF WHERE THE COMMITTEES
LIMITS ARE GOING SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THA. LIKEWISE JEFF TORTILLA.
ADVOCATE WANT TO WORK ON SEEING
WHAT'S GOING ON THIS IS. BEST
PRACTICES IN. SEEING WHAT
ELECTRIFICATION REALLY NEEDS AN
INTEREST RUPTURE NEEDS. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
IS FOR THE AUTHORS BILL. SAY
NINE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS BILL. THIS THING NINE.
QUESTIONS OF THE MISTER
O'DONNELL. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I THINK THE AUTHOR OF
FOR THE BILL- AS I MENTION
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
LITTLE MORE CONVERSATION BEFORE
TODAY AND I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION- TODAY
AND I APPRECIATE THE FACT YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED TO
GREEN. OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM OUR GOODS MOVEMENT
SYSTEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK THE GREEN IT
IN A VARIETY OF WAYS CERTAINLY
AT ELECTRIFICATION MAY BE ONE
WAY BUT THERE ARE OTHER WAYS IN
FACT WE ALREADY OF ELLEN G.
CNG. IN OUR PORTS WE HAVE SOME
ELECTRIC TRUCKS THAT ARE STILL
IN THE TESTING STAGE I WOULDN'T
PLAYING THEM IS VIABLE TODAY SO
I THINK- QUESTION ARISES WHAT
ALTERNATELY THIS EQUIPMENT
WOULD EVEN LOOK LIKE WHEN THE
TRUCKS MAY OR MAY NOT EVEN
EXIST YET BUT I MEAN I KNOW
THAT YOU YOU RECOGNIZE AS A
QUESTION THAT NEEDS TO BE.
THOUGHT THROUGH AND REALLY- YOU
WOULDN'T WANT THESE JUST IN THE
PORT. YES THESE TRUCKS DRIVE
OUT OF THE PORT. THE DRIVE TO
YOUR DISTRICT IF YOU HAVE OR
YOU HAVE WAREHOUSES IN YOUR
DISTRICT YOU HAVE TRUCKS YOU'RE
DISTRICTS HAVE. IT'S HARDER
WHATEVER MAYBE YOUR DISTRIBUTOR
TRUCKS YOU'RE DISTRICTS SO YOU
WOULDN'T WANT THEM ONLY IN THE
PORT OF JUST KIND OF SOMETIMES
A LITTLE. LITTLE SENSE AROUND
THE PORTS BECAUSE THEY ARE
DOING A LOT. THE PORTS ARE
DOING A LOT TO GREEN-
THEMSELVES AND THE INDUSTRY
AROUND THEM SO I JUST REALLY
WANT TO RECOGNIZE ALL THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE. THROUGH A LOT
OF CAR MANDATES THROUGH A LOT
OF NOT JUST REGULATION IS
SIMPLY INNOVATION. THAT'S WHY
MY APPROACH IS USUALLY NOT JUST
REGULATION INNOVATION. AND I
JUST APPRECIATE THAT- THERE'S
GONNA BE MORE CONVERSATION
AROUND THIS BILL AND THANK YOU
AGAIN THE- THANK YOU MISTER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR FROM MISTER GIBSON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN
OR THINK THE AUTHOR THINK IS OF
VERY THOUGHTFUL APPROACH- I WAS
EXCITED TO ONE- SO YOU'RE NOT
THAT YOU WILL BE WORKING WITH
THOSE WHO'VE ALREADY EXPRESSED-
THERE- WILLINGNESS TO
COLLABORATE WITH YOU- MISTER
THE NEW BILL TO MAKE IT BETTER
I WAS GLAD THEY WERE POSING
OPPOSING THE BILL AND IF YOU
COULD PLEASE- AT ME AS COOPER I
WOULD REALLY- ENJOYED BEING A
CO AUTHOR. I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE I THINK IT HELPS US-
THANK YOU AND GIVEN THE NUMBER.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR. SO REYES ENGINE WITH
COMMITTEE WE ONLY HAVE ONE
PERSON AT SOME OF THE MOTION BY
MISTER GIBSON DO I HAVE A
SECOND. THIS PHONE IS SECOND.
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE SURE I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS YOU KNOW I DO
REPRESENT THE TRI VALLEY THE
VERY WHICH GETS A LOT OF THE
TRUCK TRAFFIC FROM THE OAKLAND
PORT TO THE FIVE AND SO I
UNDERSTAND IMPORTANT TO MAKING
SURE WE HAVE GREEN
TRANSPORTATION MOVING TO AND
FROM AIRPORTS BUT IT I AM
EXCITED TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU
AND WITH THEM. THE FED FORWARD
TODAY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WORKS FOR THE FUTURE AND WE CAN
ACTUALLY REACH OUR GOALS OF
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BECAUSE THIS HAS TO
BE A START PART OF THE PUZZLE.
SO I EXPECT LAST YEAR I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER FIRST I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
PORTS HAVE BEEN AMAZING WHEN
THEY LOOK AT MOVING FORWARD AS
MEN SO WE RODE ON WAS MENTIONED.
WAY BEFORE THE WE MANDATED DUE
TO DO SO BEEN A GOOD PARTNER.
AND LOOKING AT THE DIFFERENT
KIND OF. ELEMENTS THAT CAN.
HOPE TO GO GREEN IS SOMETHING
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT I THINK
WE NEEDED TO BE MENTIONED
HYDROGEN. SO LOOKING FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING ALL TECHNOLOGIES
MOVE GOING FORWARD IS
IMPERATIVE PUT THIS IS A STEP-
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF A- TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT THE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN PLACE TO
REACH UP. I WOULD SAY ALL OF
OUR LOFTY GOALS BUT FOR CLEAN
VEHICLES BUT I WILL SAY. I KNOW
SOME CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED
AND I KNOW THAT- YOU'RE WILLING
TO WORK WITH- THE FOLKS THAT
ARE CONCERNED MOVING FORWARD.
SO WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING I'LL
BE ANNOYED TODAY SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. FRAZIER HI THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE FONG
FONG HI AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN
BERMAN I CHIU. CHIU AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I DAILY
DAILY ID FRIEDMAN. GIPSON
GIPSON I AGREE SENATE. REASON I
KILEY KILEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA I
IN THIS AREA. NAZARIAN AYE
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I. HAS
TWELVE WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ PLEASE. DEFINITELY SIR
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY WILL FURTHER
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE CHANGE AND
EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOALS BY
INCREASING YOUTH ACCESS TO
PUBLIC TRANSIT SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE LOCAL
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO OFFER FREE
TRANSIT PASSES TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS AGE EIGHTEEN AND
UNDER REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR
EDUCATIONAL STATUS. IS
CALIFORNIA BEGINS TO FACE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE CHANGE
THE STATE MUST CONTINUE TO
PROMOTE ACTIVITIES REDUCE
INDIVIDUAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THAT INCLUDES THE USE
OF PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
WITHOUT OFFENDING OUR BUDGET
CHAIR I WILL SAY WE ARE NEVER
GOING TO MEET OUR MISSION
SCHOOLS THROUGH E. VIS ALONE
AND A YOUNG CALIFORNIANS MUST
BECOME REGULAR LIFELONG TRANSIT
USERS REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR
EDUCATION STATUS. AND THIS WILL
HELP YOUTH WRITERS PROVIDE
TANGIBLE BENEFITS TO USERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES INCLUDE.
INCLUDING ABILITY COMMUTE TO
AND FROM SCHOOL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AFTER A FEW.
SUPPORTERS. THANK YOU SOMEONE
NUMBER GONZALEZ GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE FRAZIER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOE FULL
BORE HUH I'D REPRESENTS
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT- WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
THE AUTHOR IS DONE IN THIS BILL
AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS- TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
IS DOWN ALL THROUGHOUT THE
NATION BUT WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY POINT OUT THAT
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT HAS
BEEN QUOTED BY THE WASHINGTON
POST THAT'S ONE OF THE FEW
CITIES IN AN AGEOF WRITERS
DECLINE AS ACTUALLY STEADILY
INCREASING THEIR RIDERSHIP. AS
QUOTED- LAST YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN WE ARE DELIGHTED TO
PRESENT THIS BILL TODAY- SHARE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE SUCCESS
OF A WRITER T. PROGRAM WE
COULDN'T HAVE DONE THIS WITHOUT
THE- STRONG INVESTMENT BY THE
CITY SACRAMENTO AS WELL AS HER
PARTNERS CITIES AS WELL AS THE
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
WITHOUT FURTHER TO LIKE TO
PRESENT COUNCILMEMBER JAYSH
NEAR HE IS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER MEMBER AS WELL ASPEN ARE
CHEAP BOARD MEMBERS YES MA'AM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY
AND THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL THIS IS WONDERFUL-
YOU KNOW THERE ARE MANY TIMES
WHERE A LOT OF ADULTS GET
TOGETHER FROM DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND ACTUALLY DO
THE RIGHT THING FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE BUT THIS IS A PLACE
WHERE WE'VE DONE THAT WHERE YOU
HAVE THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL TRANSIT A NUMBER OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN A
NUMBER OF OUR COMPANY CITIES IN
THE COUNTY HAVE GOTTEN TOGETHER
AND THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE GET WHAT. THEY
NEED TO GO. WHEN THEY NEEDED
AND. HI COST- YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY POLICIES. THIS IS TO GET A
ONE FOR TWO FOR A THREE FOR
THIS IS ACTUALLY A SX FOR. IF
I CAN RUN IT DOWN REALLY
QUICKLY FOR YOU ON THE
BENEFITS. FOR REGIONAL TRANSIT
AS ASSEMBLY WOMAN SAID WE WANT
TO CREATE. CHOICE WRITERS WHO
ON LIFETIME WRITERS. SO ITS
CULTURE AND HAVE IT IF WE CAN
START YOUNG PEOPLE EARLY. ON
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION CHANCES
ARE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. FOR THE
SCHOOLS YOU HAVE TWO THINGS
GOING ON ONE IS YOU CAN'T TEACH
KIDS. IF THEY'RE NOT IN THEIR
SEATS. SO THAT'S IMPORTANT- WE
KNOW THAT- WHEN WE LOOK A
CHRONIC ABSENCE. THE NUMBER ONE
REASON FOR CHRONIC ABSENCES
TRANSPORTATION. ACCORDING TO
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE SO DOING THIS.
GETS KIDS TO SCHOOL WE ALSO
KNOW THAT SCHOOLS ARE FUNDED
THROUGH EIGHTY EIGHT SO WHEN WE
HAVE MORE. YOUNG PEOPLE IN
SCHOOL THE SCHOOLS TO BETTER
ECONOMICALLY. WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WE'RE DOING A LOT
OF INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WITHIN SACRAMENTO-
WE WANT YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO GET JOBS GETTING TO AND FROM
THOSE JOBS IS IMPORTANT. THIS
IS ANOTHER WAY THAT THEY CAN DO
IT WITHOUT SPENDING. A GOOD
CHUNK OF THE DOLLARS THAT THEY
WOULD TURN. ON TRANSPORTATION
WE KNOW THAT ENVIRONMENTALLY IT
RELIEVES CONGESTION BY GETTING
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS IT'S
BETTER FOR THE ENVIRONMENT. AND
JUST AN OVERALL QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
GET TO WHERE THEY NEED TO GO
WHEN THEY NEED TO GO HAS MADE A
BIG DIFFERENCE. WE STARTED THIS
PROGRAM OCTOBER FIRST- SINCE
THAT PERIOD OF TIME. WE'VE HAD
A 422403% INCREASE OVERALL. IN
STUDENT WRITER SAID. IN
DECEMBER WHERE WE USUALLY DEBT
AND LAST YEAR WE DID A TEN
DOLLAR. EXPERIMENT THIS
DECEMBER WE HAD A 72% INCREASE
IN STUDENT RIDERSHIP. SO WE
KNOW THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
DOING THIS ARE GETTING WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE. AND AGAIN THIS
IS A QUALITY OF LIFE ISSUE WE
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO EXPAND THAT
AND KEEP IT GOING. AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL. THE STEP TOWARD.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL PIMENTEL HERE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS BILL-
AND AS YOU HEARD FROM SECRETARY
WE HAVE SEEN WILK EXPERIENCES
THAT SUGGESTS THAT FREE OR
DISCOUNTED TRANSIT PASSES- DO
INCREASE TRANSIT RIDERSHIP ONE
SUPPORTER MEMBERS IN DOING
THAT. WE DO HAVE SOME GENERAL
QUESTIONS PERHAPS SOME CONCERNS
AROUND OF THE FINANCIAL AND
OPERATIONAL IMPACTS OF THE BILL
ON A TRANSIT AGENCY MEMBERS WE
REALLY DO HOPE TO HAVE A
CONSTRUCTIVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE. AROUND
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE THE BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT TECH
OF SEEING A TRANS OPERATIONS
ARE FINANCIAL BUDGETS IN OTHER
SENSES. THANK YOU. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M WILL BEAR WITH
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT. DANIEL BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. JOSH
WAS STARK ON BEHALF OF
TRANSFORMING ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT AND REALLY
ENCOURAGED BY THIS BILL THANK
YOU. ET IRONS BE ON BEHALF OF
POLICY LINK IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OR REALLY ONE I STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE AND INTERNET
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. AND LEASE STUDENT OF
UC DAVIS AND ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA INTERN IN SUPPORT.
JEFF THIRTY KIA AN APPLICANT A
WRITER AND I WILL ALSO OFFER-
INS SAN FRANCISCO WAS WHERE I
WAS A STUDENT STARTING AND AT
AMERICAN RIVERS WHERE I RETURN
TO THAT SHOULD WE SEE WHILE
RIDING THE BUS. THIS IS
SOMETHING IS GOOD IT NEEDS TO
HAVE SOME MORE WORK BUT IT'S A
BETTER IDEA. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
WHO LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL. SEEING
NONE HE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR IT CAN SHARE
CONCERNS WITH AUTHORS BILL.
MOVIE TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
THE OTHER. MR GIPSON. I JUST
HAVE A GOOD ACTUALLY- COMMONER
TO WHAT I BELIEVE THIS IS
INNOVATIVE THIS IS OUT OF THE
BOX THINKING I THINK THAT- IT
CERTAINLY CREATES THAT A
GENERATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
WILL LOOK AT- ONE. OUR CURRENT
CLIMATE WORRYING AND USE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION- THAT IS
ACCESSIBLE- USABLE FRIENDLY-
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS
CERTAIN THE WAY WE SHOULD BE
GOING IN TERMS OF HIS OWN
COMMAND THE AUTHOR. OF THE
COUNCIL FOR COMING AND GIVING
YOUR INPUT BECAUSE I THINK IT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE AND I THINK
IT GETS US TO WHERE WE WANT TO
GO AND ALSO I APPRECIATE THE
MESSES IS SENDING TO OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. THAT WE HAVE THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT THEM AND PUTTING THEM IN
THE FOREFRONT SOME DECISIONS SO
I THINK IT SENDS MULTIPLE
POSITIVE MESSAGES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OFFICE FOR THIS BILL
TODAY. MR USER. THANK YOU MIGHT
MISTER CHAIR- MISSED BECAUSE
ALMOST EIGHTY FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I'D LOVE TO JOIN
YOU AS A CO AUTHOR AS WELL- I
THINK IF. IF THE TRANSPORTATION
ISSUE WAS ADDRESSED IN THE WAY
THAT YOUR GOING ABOUT
ADDRESSING IT. WE MAY HAVE-
BEEN ABLE TO- NOT SEE THE
CRISIS LEVEL OF- HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING. RELATED ISSUES
THAT WE'RE HAVING RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THEY ARE INTRICATELY.
INTERTWINED WITH ONE ANOTHER
ONE TWO I THINK- MR CHU IS ALSO
BEING INSPIRED TO INTRODUCE
SOME OTHER LEGISLATION THAT ONE
THIS THAT I'M PROBABLY GONNA BE
JOINING HIM. AS CO AUTHORS
SWELLED SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS ROAD. YES SIR THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD
CONCEPT IS A HELP KIDS GET TO
SCHOOL MANY KIDS ALREADY TAKE
THE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IS
THEIR MONEY IN THIS BILL OR IS
THIS JUST GONNA BE A MANDATE
AND THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO. HOW
DOES IT WAS THE COST I HAPPEN
TO BE MARRIED TO SOMEBODY WHO
IS THE HEAD OF OUR- MTS IN SAN
DIEGO WHICH IS THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM SO I HEAR
ABOUT THIS EVERY DAY WE I KNOW
WE NEED A FUNDING SOURCE- WE
LOOK I REALLY WOULD LIKE US TO
START HAVING I THINK THAT
PASSED CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
YOUTH. TRANSIT PASSES HAVE BEEN
AROUND NEED- FINANCIAL NEED
WHICH IS NO IT'S GREAT- BUT
THAT DOESN'T GET US TO GETTING
TRANSIT REGULAR NORMALIZE
BASICALLY IN USE BY THE GENERAL
PUBLIC AS EIGHT WAY TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE I WOULD LOVE TO
BE ABLE TO ACCESS SOME OF THE
DOLLARS THAT WE TALK ABOUT
CABBAGE IN THAT TO ACTUALLY
READ THAT WILL ACTUALLY SEE TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS- ALONG WITH
WORKING WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TECHNICALLY WE HAVE A APPROACH
AND WE'RE WORKING ON NOW
BECAUSE OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT HAD
TO CUT BACK THE- WALKING THREE
AND A HALF. MILES TO SCHOOL BUS
RIGHT BUT OUT. ARE THE FACT WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
BECAUSE I'LL SEE YOU. ON FROM
MY LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL MY SCHOOL
TEACHER. THE C. BUSLOADS OF
KIDS COME OFF THAT BUS INTO
GOOD THING. YOU KNOW THEY'RE
GETTING TO SCHOOL AND WE'RE
HELPING HELPING THEM GET THE
SCHOOL BECAUSE- NOT ALWAYS TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PROVIDE THAT
THAT TRANSPORTATION SO AGAIN
THAT'S A GOOD THING. THE
QUESTIONS HOUSE I PAY FOR THAT
WE AT LEAST A LOOK AT SOME SOME
POTS OF MONEY AROUND THE STATE.
AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENT ABOUT CAPITA RATE
ACTUALLY USING IT. TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES. NOT JUST
WATER HAD SHOT ACTUALLY USING
IT. TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SO I HOPE YOU HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION. POINT FOUR
BUT I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REGULAR CURRY. I
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER BRING
THIS FORWARD AND I DID WALK
THREE AND A HALF MILES AND SNOW
SO YOU KNOW JUST LET ME KNOW-
SO I'M TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BUT I AGREE THAT WE HAVE
TO ENCOURAGE TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
WITH OUR YOUTH AND TO PROMOTE
LIFELONG TRANSIT USERS HOWEVER
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF THIS BILL ON SMALLER TRANSIT
AGENCIES LIKE THOSE IN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FOR I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS BILL COMES UP
WHEN IT COMES TO FOR THE MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T LEAVE SOME
PEOPLE UP- AND I'M YOU KNOW I
WILL FIGHT FOR MY RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND MY SMALLER
AGENCIES. I LOVE THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL I THINK THERE'S NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT BUT- I REALLY
WANT THEM YOU TO CONSIDER THAT
AS YOU MOVE THE BILL FOR IT.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A
KEEP MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD I
AM I WOULD BE DEFINITELY BE
HAPPY TO ADD THAT AS A CO
AUTHOR YEAH I DON'T BELIEVE THE
COST IS A BIG FACTORAT LEAST
FROM WHAT I OF A REPRESENT THE
SENATE SANTA CLARA COUNTY-
REVENUE LIKE IS ONLY LIKE NINE
PERCENT. OF THE REVENUE IS FROM
THE FARE BOX SO ADDING MORE
STUDENT TO THE EMPTY BOX THE
BUSES I DON'T SEE WILL CREATE
ANY OF FINANCIAL HARDSHIP TO
OUR TRANSIT OPERATORS AND BUT
IT WOULD DEFINITELY BENEFIT OUR
OUR STUDENTS AND HOPEFULLY YOU
KNOW LIKE THAT BEING SAID OF
MANY TOP YOU WERE. THE
ENCOURAGED A CULTURE OF USING.
THE PUBLIC TRANSIT SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SUMMARY ARE YOU WILLING TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
I GUESS. ALRIGHT I'M SORRY I IT
SOMEHOW MISS THAT SO YES
ABSOLUTELY I. ONE RIGHT UP
FRONT. ALREADY VOTE WAS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU- WAS LIKE BECAUSE
I JUST WANT TO SAY I HEAR YOU
ON CALL AND THE COST IS
SOMETHING I LITERALLY HERE
ABOUT EVERY SINGLE DAY IN MY
HOUSEHOLD- SO I UNDERSTAND
WE'VE GOT TO FIND A SOLUTION
THAT WORKS FOR A BIG TRANSIT
AGENCIES AND SMALL ONES AND ONE
RELY HEAVILY ON THE FAREBOX
RECOVERY IN THOSE WHO DON'T- I
THINK WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION THOUGH AND WHAT IT'S
NOT IT IN FOR YEARS I'VE- BEEN
PUSHING THIS LOCALLY- FOR MY
COMMUNITY WHERE KIDS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS FOR EXAMPLE ON TWELVE
MILES THE BEACH BY. BEACH
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET THERE
RIGHT TALKING TO A WHILE BUT IT
WAS REALLY- WATCHING MY
DAUGHTER'S EXPERIENCE THAT GOT
ME TO THINK ABOUT THIS IN A
DIFFERENT WAY AND THAT WE CAN'T
THINK OF PUBLIC TRANSIT IT'S
ONLY THOSE WHO ARE POOR- I HAD
ADOPTED WHICH TO YORK. RIGHT
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AND LEARN TO
USE PUBLIC TRANSIT AS A NORMAL
SHE NOW LIVES IN LA AND DOES
NOT A CAR SHE CAN ACTUALLY
EVERY SHE NEEDS TO GO BY PUBLIC.
SAID I DON'T THINK. WE HAVE HAD.
CONSTANTLY LINE ON PUBLIC
TRANSIT THAT WE WOULD HAVE
SOMEBODY WILLING TO GIVE UP AT
TWENTY THREE A CAR- BECAUSE
LIKE WHY DO YOU WANT TO SEND
TRAFFIC I MEAN TO HER IT'S SO
OBVIOUS- WE HAVE TO GET PEOPLE
TO CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR AND
FOR EVER GOING TO MEET OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS EVER WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO YOU KNOW
DRASTICALLY REDUCE EMISSIONS
COMING FROM CARS AND IT'S A
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION TO HAVE
AND NOBODY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
IT EXCEPT YOU KNOW- IN TERMS OF
LEVI'S OR KIND OF AROUND THE
EDGES BUT WE REALLY HAVE TO GET
PEOPLE TO WRITE RELY MORE
HEAVILY ON PUBLIC TRANSIT FOR
THAT TO WORK WE HAVE TO GET
MORE PEOPLE INTO- PUBLIC
TRANSIT WHEN THEY'RE YOUNG SAID
THEY'LL PAY FOR IT WHEN THEY
GET OLDER. AND I THINK THIS IS
A AN APPROACH THAT WILL WILL
HELP US DO THAT SO I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH LARGE AND
SMALL DISEASE FIGURE OUT HOW WE
PAY FOR IT. BUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY HOPE TO MOVE THIS.
SO THANK YOU FOR USE FOR TO US
TODAY. HI TO BELIEVE THE PEOPLE
RIGHT TRANSIT AT A YOUNG AGE
WILL GROW INTO LIFELONG
WRITERS. AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING. WELL I THINK YOUR BILL
IS A GOOD START TOWARDS THIS
GOAL I KNOW THERE WILL BE
CHALLENGES FOR SOME TRANSIT
ABLE TO FIND SOLUTIONS FOR THEM.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY- BUT EXPECT THAT YOU'LL.
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE ARE COMMITTEE-
INFORMED AND ON AS IT
PROGRESSES MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER PARK FRAZIER AYE FONG
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE GEAR
CURRY I BERMAN BERMAN AYE CHU
CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I. DAILY. DAILY I A DEEP.
FRIEDMAN. GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON. KILEY KILEY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA I IN THIS AREA. IS THERE
AND I O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I.
TWELVE IS A THREE YEAR. GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE IT IS THIRTY WILL
LEAVE THE ROLL UP AND PERHAPS
MEMBERS THANK YOU. SECRETARY
LISTS LET THE CALL. THANK YOU.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY HI
TO Q. I DEEP FRIEDMAN. IS THERE
AN- ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
YES NAZARIAN AYE REYES. GRAYSON
AYE. HI
. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
A. B. FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR POWER
QUE HAN AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MISTER DEEP. ESTHER
DEEP I. IT WAS EXCELLENT
. ALL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ MISTER DEEP MISTER DE
BY. YEAH
. VIDEO THREE. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A. B. THIRTEEN
pASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR A. B. FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I
. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FIFTEEN AYE
AYES. ITEM FOR A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY FIFTEEN EYES FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB FIFTY NINETY
FOUR FIFTEEN ICE. WELL BUSINESS
TODAY BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY WAS
UNANIMOUS. HELLO OF LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS NOW
COMPLETE THE HEARING IS
ADJOURNED